alors vous le savez ces dernières
semaines j'ai fait quelques tentatives
pour savoir si les gens qui m'entourent
et c'est à dire vous était un peu connus
ou juste des mythomanes
je vais pas vous mentir oui c'est
compliqué jusqu'à présent donc
régulièrement on fera des petits
contrôle pour voir si ça évolue
là en plus je voulais tester les
nouvelles comme daniel hains et caroline
j'y vois plus clair sur vous grâce à un
focus group avec vincent fond vous allez
voir ils sont à croquer alors cette
semaine il fallait des spécialistes pour
répondre à des questions essentielles
pour les enfants
je vais vous montrer des photos de
personnalités vous allez diriger si vous
les connaissez si vous paraît
sympathique d'accord alors est ce que
vous connaissez cette personne non mâcon
macro mais oui mais voilà et avec cet
homme à la tête de la france est ce que
tu es en confiance
oui oui c'est bien aussi
ouais il se la pète un peu maintenant
s'enchaîner au mois cédant qu est ce que
tu lui conseille de faire à jean michel
bayle blanchiment est ce que vous
trouvez sympathique nous dit la vérité
oui des fois je me dis que c'est boubers
[Musique]
mes bébés mais il ya quelque chose
est ce que vous le connaissez déjà ils
n'ont donc aller bizarre qu'est ce qu'il
tombe est c'est bien et sonel et il a
une tête à faire qu'avec ce type de
métier il travaille le travail très joli
métier une raide d'islande
la reine d'islande ça s'appelle isabelle
mots
bon mot là je pense que j'ai fait
hypnotisé on passe au suivant
il s'appelle manuel mâcon média matters
la photo dit matthieu delormeau matthieu
delormeau enduré il a fait de la
chirurgie esthétique pour hommes
c'est surtout ses yeux un peu de travers
ils sont un peu de travers il est moche
[Applaudissements]
parce que vous la connaissez déjà avion
c'est à dire c'est un avion de chasse
puis à d'avion elle a une tête de puits
ouais c'est vrai toit rebecca et inspira
à cette dame
mais est ce qu'elle paraît sympathique
nous pourquoi n'ont elles myard bien et
tient tête
c'est à dire de changer de torches
abonnés free et bk je connais moi j'ai
au cognac emmanuel ma base on a vu
depuis début mai que tu maîtrises bien
et manière neuf ans on passe au suivant
dans ce direct elle fait danse avec les
stars
on va y aller danser parce que tu l'as
vu dans quelle émission dont il n'existe
en fait tu travailles effet travail
d'hier et caroline roux sauveur non
c'est une vendeuse de malice hamouda
levier voilà droit à un moment on va te
faire souffler dans un ballon
je vois c'est très rigolo ouais c'est
juste pour vérifier quelque chose
carolin turbide
d'accord tu es mon passage suivant je
les connais alexander guignols a donc là
c'est alexandre bédat la ba oui il
s'appelle cyril cyril hanouna le fameux
la nina les fonds est vraiment fou
dangereux ou faux seins parfaits
moi je sais ce point comité s'est même
pas chroniqueur nice et il sera pour le
che se puisse et des bêtises d'accord tu
préfères les chroniqueurs je viens
j'aime bien cette idée
[Applaudissements]